[موسيقى]
مع ساعات الفجر الاولى يقضي هذا الشاب جل
وقته بمزرعته لجمع عشبه العطره المدينيه
التي حولها من هوايه زراعيه الى منتجات
مختلفه الاستخدامات
[موسيقى]
كان من المتذوقين الشاذلي ومن محبين يعني
والتذوق للاشياء العطريه التي تضاف مع
الشارع وعطره هذه احد المنتجات استمتع
بمشروب الشاي مع العطره اما ارتباطها
والله حنا كانت المزارعنا تنبت العطره
بكثره ونسوي فيها الشاعر وقلت خلني اسوي
مقهى واجيب من المنتجات
الشاي النعناع انواع الشاي جميعا بالاضافه
الى المنتجات الحلويات المديريه
[موسيقى]
اخذ احمد الحجوري على عاتقه ابرازا عشبه
العطره للزوار والسياح كمنتج محلي كان قد
غاب لفتره زمنيه طويله في ظل المنتوجات
العطريه الاخرى انا كثير جوني زوار يعني
يجون لان احنا على درب السنه ما بين الحرم
وقبى ويمرون على عطره ويستغربون المكان ده
لانه واضح ارث قديم وجميل وخصوا بمشروب
العطره يستمتعون فيه يعني شيء هويه قديمه
جميله وممتعه لهم وانت تعرف السياحه الان
فن تسخر المدينه المنوره بالكثير من
المنتوجات الزراعيه التي تلقى رواجا كبيرا
عند زوار المنطقه وتشهد معدلات زياره
مرتفعه في مواسم العمره والاعياد يعني
بتعكس كثير من تاريخنا
من ستايل من
المنتدى اللي بيقدموه انه بيلامس التاريخ
المدينه احنا متعودين على الشاهي
اللي هو بالنعناع المغربي والنعناع
الحساوي والدوش والعطره طبعا في انواع
نكهات كثيره تمام في شيء من عنده وفي شيء
منها لا
[موسيقى]
من المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه